si on réponse à la question qu'est ce
que tu veux faire quand tu seras grand
votre enfant vous réponds influenceurs
ne l'emmenez pas tout de suite chez le
psy car montrer ses abdos et prendre en
photo son petit déjeuner pourrait le
rendre riche depuis quelques années les
candidats issus de la téléréalité qui
sont devenus influenceurs ont pris une
place prédominante sur les réseaux on en
vient d'arriver à tous vas y mon
aspirateur à pois noirs
plusieurs bars le code promo à coups de
promotion de produits de voyages pont de
ceaurriz et de codes promo ses vedettes
2.0 mène la vie de rêve pendant que vous
vous usez le pousse à liker leurs
publications pour se valoriser en tant
qu influenceurs à chacun sa méthode
il y a ceux qui communiquent en couple
comme jessica et thibault qui n'hésite
pas à tous livrés à leurs followers
comme le débrief à chaud de la naissance
compliqué de leur enfant et laurent
aussi font tout à 2 une stratégie qui
rapporte puisqu'à u2 leur communauté
représente 4,1 millions de followers de
quoi générer de gros partenariats dont
chaque poste pour apporter entre cinq et
vingt mille euros
ah tiens même chose pour nabila qui à
elle seule représente 5 millions de
followers une fanbase qui en fait l'une
des reines du secteur globalement les
filles sont plus suivi que les hommes le
mari de nabila thomas vergara ne compte
que 1,5 million d'abonnés
ces 3 5 millions de moins que son épouse
même chose pour laurent qui compte 400
mille abonnés de moins que jazz et quand
on n'a pas d'enfant a présenté certains
influenceurs n'hésite pas à mettre tous
leurs atouts en avant pour motiver leurs
fans boys
quitte à oublier quelques vêtements dans
la salle de bains ou ips mais si ces
chiffres semblent hallucinant on est
encore loin des stars us à titre
d'exemple selena gomez empocherait grâce
à ces 161 millions d'abonnés 550 mille
dollars pour un seul poste sur instagram
ça donne envie de s'y mettre
et elle est avec lui regardez moi cette
bombe mais la nature ce sont les
bienvenus tu as plus de 2 millions de
fans sur instagram
c'est assez fascinant vrai vrai vrai
vrai vrais influenceurs j'ai demandé
jeudi à la vérité on a demandé à magali
berda ce que forcément c'est là c'est la
papesse jaillir la madame claude
je retiens pas non cela fait que ça veut
dire ça veut dire chef
ça veut dire que tu peux dire h à te
dire tu arrêtes ton boss c'est mieux
mais je retire c'est pas du tout que
j'ai pour lui c'est la papesse juridique
pour recevoir vraiment ce qu'ils vendent
bien ratez pas une dernière il ya un
garçon tout dur qui venait vous est tout
excité là une très jolie fille elle est
magnifique
ah bah oui mais quand même je n'ai
jamais dit que c'était une blague pour
et donc je lui dis qu'ils ont peut
recevoir vraiment quelqu'un des grands
grands influenceurs tu menaces i t3 et
parmi les 3 et avait mis là et tu
accepté de venir aujourd'hui et c'est
très gentil parce que la semaine
dernière rémi nota est venu et yquem
rien à faire dès qu'on parle de ce
métier dès qu'on parle de vous de votre
métier parce que c'est un métier il faut
le dire aujourd'hui c'est pour ça qu'on
est là c'est pas pour se moquer de vous
eh bien ça part dans tous les sens
aspect narni rouaix 6000 euros pour rémy
notait tout ça il faut que ça rentre
dans la tête des gens aujourd'hui les
grands groupes comme publicis et tout ça
c'est fini le monde a évolué et
aujourd'hui ce sont ces gens là
personnalité dit et puis on veut
comprendre pourquoi qui font qu'ils vont
vendre de la pub
donc voilà donc donc mis là tu as deux
millions de 2,2 d'instagram heures
aujourd'hui
en un mot qu'est ce qui fait son succès
qu'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui à ton
avis tu es l'une des plus grandes
installera meuse en plus grande
influence eux mêmes questions combien
mais on a tous merci
après qu'est-ce qu'il ya un secret ce
qu'il y avait une clé ça je sais pas je
pense que faut être assez constant sur
les réseaux sociaux je pense qu'il faut
aussi de donner à son public c'est à
dire que moi là bas je suis site télé
réalité donc c'est un autre concept
encore j'ai une chaîne youtube
donc ces deux choses qui sont
complètement différentes mais j'ai
accepté en fait de d'exposer toute ma
vie sur les réseaux sociaux
et je pense que c'est pour ça aussi la
vie ça veut dire les photos sexy aussi
ça marche plus on est honnête bah ouais
enfin moi personnellement si tu regardes
ont enfin si tu regarde mon instagram
il n'y a pas de faim je pense que j'ai
plus de j'aime pour des photos où je
suis complètement naturelle depuis que
j'ai fait moundir on a vu dans une
émission j'ai fait de la survie et alors
tu vois ben voilà le carton j'avais plus
de like sur le carton que sur cette
photo donc après je pense que ça dépend
de ta plume et toi pourquoi toi parce
qu'ils passent que parce que les coûts
parce que tu as créé un personnage tout
d'abord c'est la télé réalité on va pas
se mentir parce que c'est quand même ça
c'est quelque chose qui nous donne de la
visibilité je pense pas que si j'avais
fait si je n'avais pas fait de télé
réalité aujourd'hui j'aurais eu autant
de succès je sais pas façon parvenant le
passé maintenant je pense que la télé
réalité ça m'a aidé mais c'est pas tout
ça veut dire que la téléréalité ça donne
une visibilité de la lumière
mais si on cite c'est pas t'en servir à
sa part c'est comme toute chose j'ai une
chaîne youtube
j'ai aussi des marques que j'ai créée
ben je te collabore aussi avec d'autres
marques
j'avais une émission à moi qui
s'appelait sos millar donc c'est quelque
chose que je travaille
oui monsieur moi je suis désolé ya des
choses qui me gêne pas spécialement est
ce que vous avez dit vous mais qui
m'avait dit vous mathieu oui parce que
vous dites c'est fini le temps publicis
man ange non mais pas du tout pas du
tout il y a effectivement tu t'occupes
très bien un magali des gens qui sont
issus de la téléréalité ce que vous avez
rappelé qu'ils deviennent un influenceur
s'agit rien très bien mais ça représente
une toute petite partie de ce que sont
les influenceurs et ses influences heure
là les plus importants qui sont sur le
secteur haut de gamme bois copuler ou
voix et luxe il fonctionne toujours par
des grandes agences de pub il ya deux
personnes et caroline receveur qui
fonctionne très bien sur un cpu
vous avez une autre qui s'appelle jeanne
damas qui est la ligue 2 complète
surtout skis haut de gamme qui vient de
même d'ouvrir un restaurant et ces gens
là existe ça représente 95% les villages
la reid et représente une petite marque
partie du marché c'est comme si on
disait alors que je suis papa julien
lepers ozanam a bondi depuis l'amérique
excusez-moi fin je me permets moi j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour carolyn rogers
mais de base à leysin de là-bas sur
calvin de la télé réalité alors
aujourd'hui elle a réussi à faire autre
chose son image et c'est tout à son
honneur mais elle apparaît là pas
enchaîner les télé réalité comme vous
pouvez fermer ma chute je suis va
connaître des images et une chaîne
youtube a project i am et est
aujourd'hui elle va continuer je suis
pas d'accord puis je suis pas d'accord
avec vous passez dans le sens où
aujourd'hui on a je ne sais combien de
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent tous
les soirs donc on a un autre public qui
nous suit le dépenser s'arrêter quand tu
vas arrêter les téléréalités tu penses
que tu pourras continue cependant je
pense pas tu vois pas ce que regarde
j'ai stoppé pendant un an et ma chaîne
youtube a cartonné
elle souhaite mais là ça car oui c'est
justement pendant un an aujourd'hui les
annonceurs ne veulent plus de maquereaux
influenceurs c'est que des gens c'est
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup beaucoup de
followers cherche des micros influent
serait plus jamais regardé par mois ou
bien voir ça dépend en fait tout dépend
parce que ça dépend de deux postes que
j'ai ça dépense entre 20 et 50 mille
euros voyez à la joie yacou sanago mois
c'est très mauvais ce jeudi l'attaquant
portugais moi en tant que candidat mais
un chiffre d'affaires mais quand on a
gagné un chiffre d'affaires il n'y a pas
beaucoup de frais des marchés s'ils
valident pas tout à fait
oui alors effectivement je gagne ma vie
aujourd'hui que dans mon travail
précédent pas se mentir on va pas être
ingrat c'est la vérité quoi avant tu es
j'étais danseuse
oui donc ses danseuses c'est pas le même
boîtier maintenant en toute honnêteté
j'ai une société on est en france je
pense qu'on est tous déclaré on sait pas
voilà je vous quand par exemple on ne
paye 10 mille euros c'est pas dix mille
euros qui n'ont pas tous des impôts moi
ce matin 10h terminée pour les gens et
bien de 50000 euros ils pensent que
c'est dans notre poche
j'aurais aimé passionnément la chaîne
lorsque vous avez dit pas c'est que vous
vous avouez vous ne savez pas pourquoi
vous plaisait plus que les autres ce qui
pour moi est le début peut-elle va
peut-être signer la fin de vie nous
donne votre mise à jour c'est non pas du
tout monsieur lagacé dans la vôtre
spécificités moi je ne vous connaissais
pas
bravo moi je suis très heureuse trois
jeunes femmes qui réussissent bravo non
moi quand je vous ai vu sur votre
instagram
c'est générationnel donc pardon je suis
y tient un clone de kim kardashian et
j'ai l'impression que finalement
apparaître ça non mais je suis ça sera
comme vous ou alors alors déjà je suis
moi même
en plus de ça j'ai une chaîne youtube et
comme je vous disais jamais il ne
l'avait pas entendu ce que vous parlez
c'est à g donc moi je vous le dire j'ai
une chaîne youtube où justement je donne
des conseils aux jeunes femmes
je me permets de donner des conseils
parce que je ressentais moi je suis pas
quelqu'un de prétentieux je vais pas
venir en dix ans alors moi je suis bien
placée pour donner des conseils pour
faire 6 pour faire ça parce que en vrai
oui je suis connue bas je suis connue
parce que peut-être que les gens
m'aiment bien peut-être qu'aujourd'hui
j'ai une certaine notoriété et je ne
sais pas vous dire pourquoi mais
effectivement oui eh ben je fais des
tutos de maquillage
voilà je suis des tutos de maquillage je
donne également des conseils aux jeunes
femmes c'est peut-être pour ça que c'est
bon
pour des trajets des hommes sont suivis
sur snapshot déjà on si aujourd'hui les
influenceurs la majorité c'est sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est sur les story
c'est pas sur les photos instagram et
effectivement ils sont suivis ils voient
leur quotidien et cetera quelqu'un qui a
rien à dire qui a rien à donner ou qui
n'est pas vraiment comment diriger
lambda réfection ne va pas intéresser si
les gens aiment milla ou si les gens
aiment jessica ou nabila c'est parce que
sur snat
il donne des choses ils montrent leur
personnalité et de leur personnalité
c'est que les gens à gages concrets
ordinaire est ce que ça existe ou pas je
vois des petits mecs et tout ça que j'ai
jamais vue de ma vie qui ont 40 50 60 80
millions eur est ce que oui ou pas on
peut acheter ou ça peut très vite à peu
ce truc et pour avoir d'aidé mais bien
sûr ça s'achète des fois il aurait vu
quelque chose bien sûr sauf que c'est ce
que je dis moi où candidat quand je les
reçois les nouveaux jadue fait attention
ça ne tiendra pas sur le long terme
n'est pas parce qu'une centaine si elle
vous fait poster et bien que vous donnez
un code promo donc la marque elle sait
exactement combien vous ramener à la
marque je sais combien vous payez commun
vous paye et combien vous lui fait
gagner
donc si en fait vous avez un million de
followers et que vous avez vendu deux
produits jenson sa défense en tout cas
c'était hyper hyper hyper courageux de
donner tous ces montants est vrai que
j'ai vu des conseils et un gîte à
guillaume et j'ai dit [ __ ] mais c'est
j'aime bien ce que tdf et des conseils
j'ai des bons conseils je trouve
formidable
longue vie à toi merci pour ton courage